so I want to do this once correctly and
then I want to move on we all know that
the impeachment trial against Donald
Trump was a sham and we also all knew
from the start that impeachment would
never remove Donald Trump that's not
what I want to argue about today if you
are connected to reality you understand
that it's not about evidence Republicans
were simply never going to really
consider a conviction in impeachment and
if you don't believe that you're not
going to be convinced by me I think we
can skip that altogether what I want to
go through just one time with you right
now is that in the days after his
acquittal Donald Trump is in pieces
admitted to the entire basis for the
impeachment which was previously denied
he didn't do it all at once
he certainly insists that everything
that was done is fine but he's
effectively admitted to everything and
the cherry on top was his admission over
the weekend that Donald Trump did indeed
send Rudy Giuliani to Ukraine looking
for dirt on Joe Biden that was the kind
of final reversal of the lies that had
been told all along so after we do this
we we no longer will have to deal with
the farcical argument that the stuffed
Trump is accused of doing he didn't do
he did it the argument is will he be
held accountable
is it impeachable is it wrong all of
that can be debated but the facts are
now very clear so let's start going
through this we've done individual clips
for a lot of these I'm not gonna play
every video here for you but you can
find our previous coverage on each of
these items that I'm going to mention
let's go through the claims one by one
it was claimed that Trump wanted
ambassador Murray Ivanovitch out because
she was interfering with what he wanted
to do to whispers to get smear
investigations of Joe Biden Trump denied
it he said he barely knew who she was
all of that stuff that's been debunked
it was later confirmed that indeed Rudy
Giuliani admitted his role as Trump's
personal lawyer was to quote get her out
of the way referring to Murray Ivanovich
we have the audio-visual recording
eventually released by Lev Parnas Rudy
Giuliani's henchmen in which Parnas is
talking to Trump about Jovanovic and
Trump turns to someone else
the room and says take her out so that
defense is debunked Trump knew who she
was and wanted her out second it was
claimed that Trump was seeking these
investigations be announced in to Joe
Biden now Trump has not denied this he
has simply framed it as I was trying to
solve Ukrainian corruption so this one's
not even in question the only question
is was Joe Biden one of trumps
corruption related concerns in Ukraine
or was Trump really concerned about
corruption in Ukraine and he was
dabbling in a bunch of different things
investigations people as we now know
Trump never asked for any other
corruption related probe in Ukraine
about anything else
it was just Biden and he didn't even
really care about the investigation as
people have testified under oath during
the impeachment hearings Trump merely
wanted the investigation into Biden
announced those are not the actions of
someone concerned about corruption
generally so yes Trump wanted the Biden
smears and no corruption does not appear
to have been his concern and now
prominently Trump is admitting that he
did send Rudy Giuliani to hunt for dirt
on Joe Biden in Ukraine they are trying
to couch it as Trump knows Rudi is a
great tough investigator but Trump said
to Fox News personality Geraldo Rivera
in a podcast when asked whether it was
strange to send Rudi to Ukraine Trump
says he doesn't regret it and that Rudi
was acting on Trump's orders Trump
saying quote so when you tell me why did
I use Rudi and one of the things about
Rudi number one he was the best
prosecutor you know one of the best
prosecutors and the best mayor but also
other presidents had them FDR had a
lawyer who was practically you know was
totally involved with government
Eisenhower had a lawyer
they all had lawyers now this is a
complete red herring the other
presidents had lawyers that doesn't mean
they worked in a capacity to get foreign
countries to smear a potential opponent
of theirs for political gain or doesn't
mean they did any of these things but
again piece by piece
Trump admits at all Trump sent Rudi to
Ukraine for Biden investigations Trump
wanted Ukraine to announce Biden
investigations and didn't care about any
other investigations Trump wanted
Jovanovic out of the way and of course
importantly
Trump did order the military aid to
Ukraine withheld until an if Ukraine
announced the Biden investigations
ultimately they got caught so Trump
released the aide the trumpet's insists
the aide was released without the
investigations being announced so it's
all good this is like saying he failed
to commit the murder despite trying to
commit the murder because somebody
caught him in the act so therefore it's
not a crime it's not a defense
so consider the way that every claim has
fallen apart for months they said Rudy
wasn't there as a government operative
doing stuff for Trump and here is Tom
Trump telling Geraldo the I sent rudia
so the new defense is it all happened
but none of it is illegal the goal posts
moving and the standards changing before
our very eyes and on and on and on
rolling towards possible re-election
scary scary stuff Donald Trump had what
we call an upper morning there's upper
Trump and downer Trump upper Trump is
the Trump that tweets uncontrollably and
Trump this morning tweeting again and
again and again and again everything
from conspiracy theories to
disinformation
to wild attacks on people and I want to
remind you that this is not normal and
we have to balance at the David Pakman
show I think everybody has a
responsibility to balance on the one
hand we don't want to publicize what
Trump says on Twitter as reasonable
presidential speech but we also can't
ignore that while other world leaders
and past American presidents have
focused on doing their jobs we now have
a president whose Twitter feed is
indistinguishable from a sort of weird
blend of Alex Jones conspiracy theorist
and Breitbart
right-wing propagandists so let's check
it out first talking about once again
the Roger stone trial and the judge Amy
Berman Jackson quoting from of course
Fox & Friends this morning saying quote
judge Jackson now has a request for a
new trial based on the unambiguous and
self outed bias of the foreperson of the
jury who's also a lawyer by the way um
who's as opposed to who apostrophe s
4-person you're a lawyer why oh you are
as opposed to you apostrophe re you have
a duty and affirmative obligation to
reveal to us when we selected you the
existence of these tweets in which you
were so harshly negative about the
president and the people who support him
don't you think we wanted to know that
before we put you on this jury pretty
obvious he should get a new trial I
think almost any judge in the country
would order a new trial I'm not so sure
about judge Jackson I don't know then
Trump going into a three tweet spell
including an all caps tweet about Robert
Muller saying quote these were molar
prosecutors and the whole molar
investigation was illegally set up based
on a phony and now fully discredited
fake dossier capitalizing F and D lying
in forging documents to the FISA Court
and many other things now none of these
things are true none of these things are
true Trump going on to say everything
having to do with this fraudulent
investigation is badly tainted and in my
opinion should be thrown out even
Moeller statement to Congress that he
did not see me to become the FBI
director again has been proven false the
whole deal was a total scam if I wasn't
president I'd be suing everyone all over
the place and then all caps but maybe I
still will witch-hunt
then briefly drip a sort of dipping into
the crooked DN C stuff which is actually
smart to get some crossover interest
from Bernie supporters tweeting the
crooked DNC is working overtime to take
the Democrat nomination away from Bernie
again watch what happens to the
super-delegates in round two a rigged
convention Trump may be not wrong about
that one then going into another three
tweet screed about the u.s. being
difficult to deal with saying quote the
United States cannot and will not become
such a difficult place to deal with in
terms of foreign countries buying our
product including for the always used
national security excuse that our
companies will be forced to leave in
order to remain competitive we want to
sell I have seen some of the regulations
being circulated including those
contemplated by Congress and they are
ridiculous I want to make it easy to do
business with the u.s. not difficult
everyone in my administration is being
so instructed with no excuses the United
States is open for business
this is not normal but you've got to
hand it to them it said there's
something for everybody sort of a few
hours of craziness on Twitter if you are
most concerned with the DNC trying to
deny Bernie the nomination Trump is
tweeting something for you if you are
one of the folks that was bamboozled by
Trump knowing about trade and how he
would deal with the economy you have a
three treats three tweets Creed that's
hard to say that three times fast a
three tweet screed about the economy and
about the US as a place for business and
trade and so on and so forth
if you are still in the Trump is the
most persecuted victim little a little
up all that stuff then you've got Trump
going after Muller about a witch hunt
and life Aiza this that the other thing
there's something for everybody here and
you've got to zoom out and realize it's
just not normal for a president to be
doing any of this stuff regardless of
what the content here is and it may
rocket him towards re-election that's
the saddest part of the entire thing
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on Instagram for more on
this and other stories from today's show
at David Pakman show on Instagram one of
the things that's often said about
technological advancements is that when
technology is advancing really rapidly
you can't see it until later when you're
in the middle of it it can be hard to
see even rapid technological change
because you are in the midst of it every
single day we are in the middle of an
authoritarian explosion right now and if
you've been in the middle of the trump
presidency day to day as I haven't as
many of you have for the last I don't
know eleven twelve hundred days roughly
Donald Trump's presidency you likely
don't realize how quickly things have
gotten authoritarian and dictatorial we
might have some general sense of it but
what has happened in just the last two
weeks really twelve days
is shocking and if someone had told you
the day Donald Trump was inaugurated you
know in a 12 day period in 2020 here's
the list of authoritarian things this
man is going to do many of us myself
included likely would have said there's
no way it won't happen but we've slowly
been desensitized it slowly been
normalized and it has happened in the
time since Donald Trump's acquittal as
reddit user rustic guerrilla astutely
pointed out Donald Trump has vowed
revenge on his enemies list after being
acquitted in a completely sham
impeachment since the acquittal the
president said that these are people who
will suffer consequences for their role
in impeachment that includes Adam Schiff
and Jerry Nadler and other Democrats it
even includes Republican Mitt Romney for
his one guilty vote on article one of
impeachment remember impeachment is the
constitutionally outlined duty of the
house a reporter asked Trump how he's
going to get revenge on those
responsible he responded you'll see this
is dictatorial Trump then fired
impeachment witnesses who showed up and
simply told the truth under oath as they
remember it from fired
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
Trump fired ambassador to the European
Union
Gordon Sunland they did nothing wrong
Trump simply doesn't like what they said
when you tell the truth to investigators
under oath and Trump doesn't like it you
lose your job this is an authoritarian
nightmare Trump's former chief of staff
John Kelly rightly defended Colonel via
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh and Donald
Trump attacked Kelly tweeting when I
terminated John Kelly which I couldn't
do fast enough he knew full well that he
was way over his head being chief of
staff just wasn't for him he came in
with a bang went out with a whimper but
like so many X's he misses the action
and just can't keep his mouth shut which
he actually has a military and legal
obligation to do his incredible wife
Karen who I have a lot of respect for
once pulled me aside and said strongly
that Jon respects you greatly when we
are no longer here he will only speak
well of you wrong
Trump then as we've already discussed
got involved in the sentencing of his
associate Roger stone interfere
in the trial tweeting quote this is a
horrible and very unfair situation the
real crimes were on the other side as
nothing happens to them cannot allow
this miscarriage of justice again I know
I said this I'm rehashing it Trump is
using the fact that people not charged
with crimes that he happens not to like
haven't gotten prison time and therefore
stone shouldn't get seven to nine years
dictators do this
dictators attack a justice system that's
working independently and not
considering the subjects relationship to
the president then when for prosecutors
quit because of Trump's own interference
Trump attacks then - Geraldo Rivera
saying over the weekend quote I don't
think they quit for moral reasons I
think they got caught in the act by me
what am I gonna do let a man go to jail
for nine years
when murderers aren't going to jail you
have some of the most serious horrible
rapists and everything else that they
don't go to jail for nine years once
again Trump not using any factual basis
to argue that seven to nine years is
actually out of line with federal
sentencing guidelines but it's not just
the prosecutors that Trump's at Trump
attacks then Trump attacks the judge in
the case
Amy Berman Jackson's saying quote is
this the judge that put Paul Manafort in
solitary confinement something that not
even mobster Al Capone had to endure
how did she treat crooked Hillary
Clinton just asking of course remember
Hillary Clinton not charged with any
crimes and of course as I've already
told you based on the point system that
federal sentencing guidelines employ
seven to nine years was the correct
range for Roger stone and then lastly
he's attacked the prosecutors he's
attacked the judge Trump then attacks
one of the jurors in the Roger stone
trial saying quote now it looks like the
foreperson in the jury in the Roger
stone case had significant bias add that
to everything else and this is not
looking good for the quote Justice
Department then he said I didn't
intervene here but I could have if I
wanted to quote the president has never
asked me to do anything in a criminal
case AG bar
this doesn't mean that
that I do not have as president the
legal right to do so I do but I have so
far chosen not to so to sum up the
authoritarian nightmare of the Roger
stone situation you have Trump attacking
the sentence
attacking the prosecutors attacking the
judge attacking a juror and saying he
can intervene in any case if he so
pleases and then getting the Justice
Department to change their sentencing
recommendation there's not really any
Justice Department independence there
Trump then on Twitter accuses the former
director of the FBI robert muller of
lying to congress that's a crime if true
trump says congratulations to attorney
general bill bar for taking charge of a
case that was totally out of control and
perhaps should not even it should not
have even been brought evidence now
clearly shows that the Moller scam was
improperly brought and tainted even bob
muller lied to congress
that's an allegation that the former FBI
director has committed a crime casually
by the president on twitter this is what
goes on in countries that most of us do
not consider ourselves to be equivalent
to in terms of the functioning of our
systems but we are seeing it right here
this would be enough for two terms never
mind twelve days and in the same 12 day
period
I don't I won't go into it in detail
Trump attacked FBI director Christopher
R a former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe withdrew the nomination of Jesse
Lew who oversaw the Roger stone case and
McCain and McCabe's case as head of the
DC US Attorney's Office and on and on
and on so when you put together just the
last 12 days it's an authoritarian
nightmare the likes of which we have not
seen from a president in the United
States for a long time I would argue
likely ever unless someone can give me
an example of where we've seen this
level of authoritarianism not in a four
year period in a 12-day period by a
president this is nothing compared to
what we will see in a potential Trump
second term this was 12 days forget
about is it the 12 days of Christmas
that song or 12 nights of Christmas I'm
Jewish either but there's 12 nights
somewhere I don't know this is the 12
days
of authoritarianism under Donald Trump
and you could pick any 12 days and do
something similar except he's been madly
and wildly emboldened by the impeachment
acquittal which was predictable we said
this would happen it will get
significantly worse if Trump is given a
second term let me know what you think
about these last 12 days of
authoritarianism I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me and send me your
thoughts there so Donald Trump has
become completely obsessed with
Democratic presidential candidate
Michael Bloomberg and it's starting to
get weird and we've been covering this
for a little bit for the last several
weeks Donald Trump has seemed sort of
triggered by Michael Bloomberg Michael
Bloomberg putting out an ad about
Trump's golfing in which he used some
unflattering pictures of Donald Trump
Donald Trump looking obese in the
pictures that Michael Bloomberg's ad
used and Trump very much didn't like it
and the last 24 hours have seen Donald
Trump to vote other than time devoted to
pardoning people convicted of various
types of corruption Trump has devoted a
lot of the last 24 hours to tweeting and
sharing videos and doctored images of
Michael Bloomberg his Twitter feed is
simply riddled with the stuff and Trump
is becoming privately obsessed with
Michael Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg of
course will be debating tonight his
first debate in the Democratic primary
and we will see whether the the stop and
frisk stuff comes up or the leaked or
publicized audio we don't know but what
is very clear is that Donald Trump is
extremely distraught and obsessed with
Michael Bloomberg this started yesterday
with another one of his mini Mike
Bloomberg rants where Donald Trump said
quote what many Mike is doing is nothing
less than a large-scale illegal campaign
contribution he is spreading money all
over the place only to have recipients
of his cash payments many former
opponents happily joining or supporting
his campaign isn't that call the payoff
mini is illegally buying the Democrat
nomination they are taking it away from
Bernie again mini Mike major party
nominations are not for sale good luck
in the debate tomorrow night and
remember no standing on boxes
the standing on boxes thing is funny but
consider the hypocrisy here that when
Donald Trump ran in 2016
Trump bragged about how he was funding
his own campaign he was rich he's got
money he's funding his own campaign so
he's immune from the demands of donors
and now Michael Bloomberg is funding his
own campaign and Trump says it's illegal
you can be for or against the system of
campaign finance that we have I'm
against it
vociferous Lee so but Donald Trump is
criticizing Michael Bloomberg for doing
exactly the same thing that he did in
2016 the difference is Bloomberg has way
more money that's quite frankly the the
real difference between Trump and
Bloomberg and it seems to be very
triggering to Donald Trump now after
this Michael Bloomberg tweeted to Trump
why do you want to run against Bernie so
badly to which Donald Trump replied
Minnie Mike no I would rather run
against you at this point Trump switched
from tweeting words about Mike Bloomberg
to retweeting doctored images and fake
videos of Bloomberg this is the
president and he's spending his day
retweeting memes and videos of a
possible upcoming political opponent
starting by retweeting a picture of
Michael Bloomberg's head photoshopped
onto a little kids body on a debate
stage next to all the other candidates
again going on this idea that Michael
Bloomberg is is short and then slightly
later in the day retweeting a video of
Michael Bloomberg doctored to look like
Bloomberg isn't tall enough to see over
a lectern while speaking in public
somewhere unclear if Trump has realized
that this was a doctored video I don't
know that they actually care why do you
think that Trump has become so obsessed
with Michael Bloomberg is it that
Bloomberg is so much richer than Donald
Trump is it that Bloomberg is actually
spending his own money and his ad spend
is pushing Trump to have to think about
spending way more than he wants to and
probably isn't actually interested in
doing is it a New York rivalry Bloomberg
and Trump Trump the New York businessman
of Bloomberg the former New York City
Mayor is it that Bloomberg
is more successful as a businessperson
than Trump and doesn't have the multiple
bankruptcies I don't know what the
answer is I'm not a Bloomberg supporter
I'm not defending Bloomberg in any way
but what I want to understand understand
is why is it that Donald Trump Trump has
become obsessed with Michael Bloomberg
triggered by every new ad that Michael
Bloomberg puts out there and focused so
heavily on Michael Bloomberg let me know
what you think I'm thinking out loud
here I don't know the answer but I want
to hear from you
during a segment on Fox News about
Democratic presidential contender Pete
Budaj edges marriage to his husband a
fox news anchor cutoff contributor
Jessica Tarlov saying it's not
appropriate for you to bring up the
personal relationships of Donald Trump
and countless Fox News viewers failed to
see this incredible double standard this
was a segment about Pete Budaj edges
personal relationship during which
someone tried to bring up Trump's
personal relationship and was told it's
not okay to mention Trump's personal
relationship check this out and the
context is right-wing radio host Rush
Limbaugh's recent homophobic comments
about Pete Buddha judge will pick it up
there you will see Jessica Tarlov a Fox
News contributor bring up Trump's
relationships and it all just goes
haywire and she's told that's not okay
that's inappropriate Jessica so notice
that the Republican on the panel doesn't
want to talk about what the substance of
the criticism was which was a homophobic
comment me by Rush Limbaugh there it's
really interesting to me as someone who
is an open advocate obviously for
same-sex marriage which is now the law
of the land thankfully a lot of work
there by Joe Biden to do that but you
when you hear these criticisms from the
right and this has been consistent even
going from Bill Barr saying that
progressives or the secular left are
responsible for the moral decay of the
country and you see a loving monogamous
couple like pee poo to judge and chaste
and his husband up there showing what is
possible that someone who is in a
same-sex relationship could be running
for president and doing this well and
then they're torn down by Rush Limbaugh
who's been married four times I think
we've Donald Trump three times married
cheated on all of those wives
you hear it's not bring in personal
relationships but we could we could say
exactly what it is that Rush Limbaugh
says so that it's fair in the
conversation here let's not bring up
personal relationships says anchor
Sandra Smith is this satire is this a
parody the entire segment is about the
personal relationship of Peabody jej
which became a topic of homophobic ire
for Rush Limbaugh and Jessica Tarlov who
I'm not a particulars in the sense that
I don't know who she is she says if Rush
wants to talk about relationships what
about his three or four marriages
what about Rush supporting Donald Trump
who's cheated on every spouse he's had
no no no no no let's not bring personal
relationships into this
I wish Jessica Tarlov had immediately
said guys this whole segment is about
personal relationships this entire thing
is about Pete Budaj edges personal
relationship and Rush Limbaugh's opinion
of Pete Budaj edges personal
relationship and you guys are all
hypocrites but then she maybe wouldn't
be a fox news contributor anymore and I
guess we're forgetting the real
important difference here Buddha judge
is a gay Democrat while Trump is their
Lord and Savior alpha male Republican
president that's really the difference
here and this is considered journalism
among some people people or at least
sort of smart incisive commentary that's
how far we've fallen and as I was
watching this I watched it a couple
times in preparation for today's segment
when you learn to think critically lots
of things go out them out the window
Fox News is one of them when you learn
to think critically
astrology no longer makes sense to you
when you learn to think critically
supply-side trickle-down economics don't
make sense anymore multi-level marketing
for moms wanting to start their own
business working from home that stops
making sense when you start applying
critical thinking in your life
timeshare seminars stop making sense
when you think critically and in this
time of hypocrisy saying you can't talk
about personal relationships during a
segment exclusively about the personal
really
of a candidate that stops making sense
real quick when you're thinking
critically but when you're not thinking
critically this stuff apparently makes
sense to you coming up next on fox news
a segment about hypocrisy during which
you can't mention donald trump that's
effectively what we're talking about
here and you all know i'm not a Pete
booed edge supporter everybody I think
who's been watching this show for a
while knows that although I'd vote for
him over Trump of course but just
imagine for a second if on January
whatever 2021 inauguration day imagine
Pete Buddha judge and his husband
dancing at the inaugural ball these
people's heads would explode and that
would be something to see now it's not
enough to get me to support Buddha judge
in the primary but if he is indeed the
nominee I will vote for him and I will
look forward to the exploding heads when
he dances with Chaston at the inaugural
ball so not one not one hundred but more
than a thousand prosecutors have had it
with Donald Trump and his Attorney
General William bar and have signed a
letter condemning both of them over the
Roger stone case and of course the
letters not going to actually achieve
anything but it does tell us a lot about
the total failure of many of the systems
that we basically take for granted in
our country because no one has ever
challenged them or floated them the way
that the Trump administration has
remember that Donald Trump is connected
to is an associate of Roger stones or
maybe better said Roger stone is an
associate of Donald Trump's Roger stone
was indicted and he was convicted and
prosecutors recommended seven to nine
years in prison for Roger stone and
Roger stone of course has created this
entire campaign to argue how unfair
everything is Trump lost it on Twitter
the Justice Department got involved and
very quickly the recommendation went
from being seven to nine years in prison
time to simply a recommendation for some
prison time this led to multiple
prosecutors saying we can't be involved
in this resigning from the case
altogether and remember that we're
supposed to have supper
of powers and checks and balances here
in the United States we're supposed to
have independence between agencies and
branches of government it's sort of US
government 101 a lot of us learned this
in seventh grade the Justice Department
is separate from the administration the
president gets to pick the Attorney
General who heads the Justice Department
but the Justice Department should be
independently operating investigating
wrongdoing whoever it is that may have
carried it out whether it's members of
an administration or not the Justice
Department should not interfere or exert
influence in individual cases especially
for politically motivated reasons such
as the president doesn't like the
sentence that was recommended for his
associate Roger stone that's how things
are supposed to work but of course the
current form of the Republican Party is
a shameless corrupt colluding
organization that functions more like a
mob family than a major political party
so Roger stone gets convicted for crimes
he committed in the course of helping
Donald Trump get elected prosecutors
look at the facts and they say based on
the crimes seven to nine years makes
sense and it does and I'll get to that
in a second but Trump catches wind of
this and tweets quote this is a horrible
and very unfair situation the real
crimes were on the other side as nothing
happens to them cannot allow this
miscarriage of justice Donald Trump is
arguing that because people on the other
side politically who have not been
indicted nor charged nor tried nor
convicted of anything they haven't
gotten prison time because this is the
United States and people who aren't
indicted or convicted or tried don't get
prison time stone shouldn't either and
then lo and behold the recommendation
has changed from seven to nine years to
just some prison time and now 1,000
prosecutors more than a thousand
actually are furious Trump says well I
didn't tell the Justice Department to do
this which is of course ridiculous he
doesn't have to the message gets to
William Barr and the Justice Department
that Donald Trump is not pleased the
idea that they are pushing is that the
sentence is out of whack
with the crimes that have been committed
but that's not true let's go through it
federal sentencing guidelines you know
sometimes you hear about these wacky
sentences that are way too light for
certain crimes at in in local courts
these federal sentencing guidelines are
very clear and they use a point system
Roger stone obstructed justice that's 14
points there's an enhancement for
threatening physical injury to a person
that gets Roger stone eight more points
that's 22 three points for interference
with the administration of justice
another two points for extensive
planning of the crime significant
premeditation two points for willfully
obstructing or impeding justice that's
29 points the fact that he has not been
previously convicted puts him in
criminal category one and the Sentencing
Guidelines table says 87 to a hundred
and eight months that's seven to nine
years that's it there's no real
justification for a lower sentence other
than political cronyism other than this
is a guide Trump's like Trump likes and
in the yet and it's likely going to be
moot because remember that Donald Trump
can just pardon him anyway so do not let
yourself be tricked into believing that
this is some unfair sentence being
carried out by some biased jury or an
activist judge we'll get to those
allegations a little bit later what is
wrong and unfair is that Donald Trump is
getting involved what is wrong and
unamerican and unconstitutional is that
Donald Trump is arguing that because his
political enemies who have not been
charged with any crime aren't in prison
Roger stone shouldn't get seven to nine
years and this is just the tip of the
iceberg Donald Trump has an enemies list
that he wants the Justice Department to
go after he has fired impeachment
witnesses he's attacked the foreperson
of the Roger stone jury he says he can
intervene in any case for any reason if
he so pleases it's a disgustingly
authoritarian
turn and that's what I want to dig into
next in more detail it's important not
to forget to report on proven lies
from this administration even when the
story has left the headlines and case in
point we now have a Declassified
internal White House memo about that
assassination of the Iranian codes
leader Kasim soleimani which but the
memo now confirms that the imminent
threat posed by Soleimani was not
actually part of the justification that
the White House internally was
discussing for his assassination
something we suspected at the time he
was not a threat imminently to the
United States or US interests and
initially they changed the
justifications but initially that was
the primary justification that the White
House gave now remember that the
explanations shifted first it was
Soleimani was an imminent threat he was
planning to do all sorts of violence
attack US embassies all sorts of stuff
when it started to become very clear
that that wasn't true they shifted to
well this is because of the things that
soleimani did in the past and
hilariously at one point Trump and his
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo we're not
even on the same page Trump was
repeating that it was because of the
imminent threat while Pompeo had already
shifted to saying it's because of what
he did in the past
then Trump ended up tweeting well it
doesn't even really matter why I did it
saying quote the fake news media and
their Democrat partners are working hard
to determine whether or not the future
attacked by terrorists Soleimani was
imminent or not and was my team in
agreement the answer to both is a strong
yes but it doesn't really matter because
of his horrible past will we now have
the memo from the White House just to
kind of close this story out an imminent
threat is nowhere in there it's another
bogus dishonest talking point debunked
ultimately by their own documents the
only thing the memo says is that this
was a response to escalating attacks in
Prior months by Iran and Iran backed
militias the attack was meant to serve
as a sort of scare off deterrent to
future attacks and it simply then goes
into the legal justification for a why
Donald Trump was legally enabled and
able to do this attack there was nothing
there about imminent threat there's
nothing there about the image
it's claimed that they claimed existed
now I know it's been weeks people have
already forgotten about this but it's
important to document the lies and we
now have another one confirmed and in a
sense we already had it confirmed Mike
Pompeo very quickly shifted from
imminent threat to repercussions for
past actions reminder of one of Pohnpei
o's being slippery on this at the time
we needed a strike to make sure that
this imminent attack that he was working
actively was disrupted a specific target
overseas I'm not gonna say anything more
about the nature of the tech but know
that this was not just in Iraq was
throughout the region I was using these
proxy forces that he has manipulated for
so long to drink so much destruction to
the Shias and Sunnis the Muslims
throughout the region this a man who
inflicted enormous arm not only on
American lives but created terribly
destructive activities sporting Lebanese
Hezbollah Hamas the Palestinian Lama
jihad all of the bad actors in the
middle of my Qasem Soleimani was at the
center of all of it
was there any imminent threat to the US
homeland these were threats that were
located in the region right I mean I
guess maybe some threat in that region
not to the US and anyway it was
punishment for bad things he previously
did as they later went on to say and
Trump insisting he can do it either way
no matter what then Pompeo went on Fox
News and said well probably there was
some threat we just didn't know when or
where it would ultimately manifest and
then it went back to well no no it was
actually punishment for Kasim Soleimani
'he's past bad deeds it was a completely
incoherent shifting rationale from the
start we knew they were lying
and now the Declassified White House
memo confirms this not that anybody on
Trump's side is going to care but
important to do the work and to keep up
with debunking these lies and there are
many of them and they come fast and
furious so the Democratic primary is
taking very interesting shape over the
last 10 days and the stories have big
picture been Bernie climbing Bloomberg
climbing Biden falling with Bernie
taking the lead and
last week Michael Bloomberg passing Pete
Buddha judge and getting into third
place and as you know I've been saying
that despite the very damaging audio and
video of Michael Bloomberg which heavily
publicizes lately his horribly
insensitive comments about stop and
frisk and race I have been saying that
Bloomberg is going to end up doing way
better than anybody was thinking when he
entered this race and case in point
breaking news we have a new poll with
Michael Bloomberg and second place
qualifying qualifying for tomorrow's
debate in Nevada ahead of the Nevada
caucuses the poll is an NPR PBS Marist
Poll of 1,400 adults
it has Bernie Sanders with an even
bigger lead than we've previously seen
Bloomberg in second place let's look at
the poll results Bernie at 31% a massive
lead over Bloomberg at 19% in second
place Biden in third at 15 Warren in
fourth at 12 Clovis Shar in fifth with 9
and in this poll mayor Pete has fallen
to sixth place with 8 percent of the
vote a complete reversal from his recent
momentum in Iowa and New Hampshire
Bernie in this poll since December
gaining 9 points Bloomberg gaining 15
since December and the biggest loser
Biden going from 24 in this same poll
back in December losing 9 points to 15
so let's talk about the Bloomberg stuff
a little bit there's been a major online
effort to attack Michael Bloomberg as
this racist oligarch buying his way into
the election which is not a completely
inaccurate framing but it may not be
working I said early last week when our
good friend Ben Dixon publicized this
horrible stop-and-frisk audio that it
may not have a significant effect on
Michael Bloomberg support and so far his
support at least in this poll has
continued to increase now I don't
believe Michael Bloomberg will be the
nominee but he is going to be a factor
in determining who the nominee is even
if it's merely by picking up just enough
delegates to prevent Bernie Sanders from
getting the nomination which may be
increasingly the role for Michael
Bloomberg as the Democratic
establishment may see it but what is
important in the immediate in terms of
how this changes the dynamic of the race
is that Michael Bloomberg has now
qualified for the debate in Nevada just
as we predicted he would based on the
rule changes from the DNC which remove
individual donors as a fund rate as a
qualification criteria and now not only
do you have Michael Bloomberg spending
but according to one report is more than
300 million dollars pouring it into ads
all over the place internet television
radio I'm not sure about but possibly
radio you now will have that money
continuing to pour in and Michael
Bloomberg on the debate stage ahead of
Nevada giving voters across the country
their first look at Bloomberg in a
debate now if he doesn't do well in the
debate this may be self-destructive if
you believe that he will show up with at
least more energy than Biden and maybe
getting more speaking time than Warren
and Buddha judged based on the recent
polling it's conceivable that the
combination of Bloomberg at the debate
and Bloomberg continuing to pour
hundreds of millions of dollars in is
going to continue giving him lift
meanwhile the next primary is as I
mentioned the Nevada caucus it's on
Saturday the very good news for Bernie
Sanders there are two new polls this
month
Bernie ahead in both Bernie leading by
19 in Nevada in the latest DF people 35
to 16 over second place Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie leading by 7 in the Las Vegas
Review Journal poll 25 to 18 and then
lastly in our look at the polls in South
Carolina Biden as of now still in the
lead Bernie ins second Tom Steyer in
third steyr needs some delegates there
in order to justify continuing past
February 29th which is when South
Carolina will vote otherwise Tom Steyer
should likely exit before Super Tuesday
so there are two movements that are
getting very agitated right now you have
the establishment stop Bernie movement
they are trying to figure out what's
their best bet
it's clear that supporting Joe Biden was
not the right bet Biden now polling
fourth even fifth in some places so do
they move their support from Biden to
mayor Pete do they consider Amy
Klobuchar do they abandon the sort of
centrist establishment Democrats
altogether and go to Bloomberg who is a
Republican for much of the last 20 years
and meanwhile you have a stop Bloomberg
movement from those who have realized
that Bloomberg's massive polling gains
may end up being what prevents Bernie
not from getting a plurality of the
delegates he still may
but what prevents Bernie from getting
50% plus one which is what's required to
secure the nomination and prevent
super-delegates from getting to vote at
the DNC right now the five thirty
eight.com odds for the Democratic
nomination are even money between Bernie
securing the nomination versus no one
securing the nomination and thus forcing
a contested convention two and five odds
for both followed by a Biden nomination
as the next most likely scenario at 12%
the next 14 days will tell us probably
90% of what we need to know about this
democratic nomination process I believe
that by Super Tuesday which is two weeks
from today by the end of Super Tuesday
we will be able to say with 90%
certainty what the future of the
Democratic nomination this year is going
to be